whether you love it hate it or never  thought about it chances are some nanny  wants to ban it presenting the nanny of  the month runners up the city of San  Francisco for Melina ban on bottled  water on city property we are going to  be kind of on the progressive wave of  animal welfare and the city of San  Francisco for just maybe forbidding the  sale of most kinds of pets the city  makes it more and more difficult to do  business but there's only one nanny of  the month and this time it's I'm Gavin  Newsom mayor of San Francisco Newsom  yanked calorically sweetened soda from  vending machines on city property we  have an eating and drinking problem in  the United States of America or maybe we  have a nanny problem today soda  maybe it's Sundays tomorrow and then  Doritos etc etc etc Bravo San Francisco  you scored the first ever nanny of the  month trifecta where does it all end  check back next month for more examples  of busybodies minding your own business  you